Ciao ragazzi e benvenuti in questo nuovissimo video. Mi avete chiesto dopo il video degli outfit di natale....
Mi avete chiesto anche il video sugli outfit per capodanno chiaramente perchè se ci manda in paranoia l'outfit di natale
quello capodanno, non ve dico, insomma...vi starete chiedendo perchè sono in pigiama
perchè volevo immedesimarmi in voi che in questo momento sarete
in pigiama a casa che sfrugate dentro l'armadio per capire che diavolo mettere a capodanno
Quindi! La prima cosa che vi consiglio di fare è sicuramente di truccarvi un po' e pettinarvi..insomma, fare proprio le prove generali
Diciamoci la verità, come fosse un saggio di danza, quindi, trucco parrucco e sicuramente qualsiasi vestito che proverete vi starà meglio
di quando siete magari struccate, appena sveglie con i capelli arruffati..ma questo già lo sapevate
Quindi! Partiamo subito, ma aspettate un attimo! perchè io devo salutare 3 di voi!
Saluto Milena Atta! Noemi Zago e Cinesiina!
Se volete farvi salutare nel prossimo video ricordatevi di seguire le istruzioni che vi lascierò qui alla fine del video!
Ma! Passiamo subito agli outfit per capodanno
(Imita Chiara Ferragni) Questo è il mio primo outfit per capodanno
Allora, proprio come ho fatto per il video sugli outfit di Natale anche questa volta
dividerò gli outfit a gruppi con i loro hashtag d' appartenenza
questo chiaramente appartiene a
i neri che sono i sempreverdi, gli ever green
di un armadio di una ragazza
ecco, non manca mai il vestito nero... a maggior ragione se si parla di un tubino
che bene o male abbiamo tutte, quindi quello che potrei consigliare
se proprio non riuscite a fare a meno del vostro tubino nero
o non riuscite a trovare alternative e uscite sempre con il nero
lasciatevi il nero anche per il capodanno
ma magari arricchitelo con un particolare: tipo degli orecchini proprio... belli esagerati
e la borsetta
Dov'è finita? L' ho lanciata
la vado subito a prendere
e la pochettina glitterata. Ecco questo penso che sia...
...un buon compromesso
per essere sempre con il vostro tubino nero
amato e che mettete sempre, però per capodanno per renderlo un po' più (?)
(Se vi state chiedendo come ho fatto a passare dai capelli che avevo all'inizio del video
a questo chignon, bè vuol dire che vi siete persi il video sulle acconciature: "Le 4 acconciature per le feste"
vi metto il link qui, in descrizione, andatevelo a vedere
e copiatemi subito questa pettinatura che io trovo veramente TOP, ADOROH)
e approposito di neri, di sobrietà, di Maryna...
l'ho comprato da poco e non l'avevo ancora provato fino ad adesso
lo trovo veramente fantastico
molto esagerato, però per capodanno, secondo me ci sta
ceh se non lo metti a capodanno, quando lo metti?!
Quindi se a capodanno volete sia essere sexy, ma anche da fare qualche rapina ad una qualche banca
potete mettere questa
ed io ADOROH
Ma passiamo al secondo hashtag che è i rossi, c'erano anche a Natale, ma ci sono ache a Capodanno
perchè il  rosso fa subito festa,  questo vestito fa subito Capodanno perchè è bello forte
con questo corpetto non indifferente, mi sento molto la regina di cuori
ma vediamo subito il secondo vestito rosso
...allora, l'ho preso da poco ed era la prima volta che me lo provavo, Edoardo testimone, ho appena detto:
"Ho trovato il vestito per Capodanno... mi sa che ho quasi deciso per lui perchè è TOP"
fa sempre parte dei rossi, ma è veramente molto
..come dire...Spanish
(canticchia)
e niente, mi piace. E' anche molto comodo e si può ballare, guarda
mh hahahaha (lei ride ride ride, cit.)
(accento spagnolo) "Per un capodanno pieno di passione, vestiti anche tu con il vestito scollato"
Ma non è Capodanno senza PAILLETTES
e quindi, l' hashtag è paillettati. Abbiamo il paillettato oro, che avrete visto in un po' di video miei
uno anche molto recente.
Questo vestito ha una storia che vi devo raccontare: l'avevo preso per i miei 18 anni
era più largo e più lungo perchè io avevo qualche taglia in più
ai tempi, lo feci tagliare perchè lo volevo più corto
poi dimagrendo, l'ho fatto anche stringere. Insomma è un altro vestito rispetto a quello che avevo comprato
Però, resistente perchè sono anni che continua ad essere un bel vestito,. molto paillettoso.
Passiamo alle paillettes di un altro colore
e approposito di paillettes
una pailettes, insomma, molto  stilosa perchè questo modello
sembro quasi anni '80, anzi è molto ispirato agli anni '80 ed è subito "regina del ballo anni '80".
Ho messo anche questo per alcuni video... stavo appunto dicendo che non l'ho mai messo per uscire
cioè l'ho usato solo per fare video
DEVO trovare una serata a Milano dove poterlo mettere
quindi si accettano consigli
detto questo passiamo al prossimo hashtag
Ma passiamo ad un must per Maryna che è l'oro, chiaramente ormai lo sapete
questo vestito, mi sta un po' larghino perchè  è di un po' di anni fa, l'ho utilizzato per un Capodanno molto speciale
molto bello, passato con la mamma a Dubai
... niente lo trovo molto in stile greco, molto Versace, ma non è di Versace
non mi ricordo di che marca è comunque l'avevo pagato abbastanza poco, ma fa un figurone
quindi per un Capodanno super elegante, super chic, un bell' abito lungo oro e si VOLAH
APPROPOSITO DI ORO,  NON poteva mancare un abbinamento OROH-NERO , come sempre c'è
questa pochettina, di mia mamma perciò vintage e anni '80, che è oro-nero, quindi TOP
non ci sta niente, ma è top e c' è questo abbinamento di body nero molto scollato, dietro tutta la schiena scoperta
e panta-collant oro quindi oro-nero
molto poco sobrio, carico e molto Maryna
e per la donna aggressiva che non deve chiedere mai, questo è l'outfit giusto
sotto Donatella Versace, sopra rock and roll
l'ho intitolato l'aggressivo
ma lo trovo molto TOP,  per un Capodanno indimenticabile
e sopprattutto molto, ma molto
borchiato
Siamo giunti al termine anche di questo video sugli outfit di Capodanno
spero tra quelli di Natale e Capodanno di avervi aiutato
a trovare gli outfit giusti per queste feste, fatemi sapere quale di questi outfit avete preferito
quale non mettereste mai, quale avete preferito, ma sopprattutto se avete già scelto o meno il vostro outfit
per la serata di Capodanno. Vi ricordo che se volete essere salutati nel mio prossimo video
non dovete far altro che seguire questi piccoli step
1. Seguirmi su Instagram
2.Scrivermi un bel direct con scritto : "Ciao, mi chiamo (...), mi saluteresti perfavore?"
3. Guardare il prossimo video per vedere se siete tra i fortunati
che SALUTEROOOO'
se il video vi è piaciuto, lasciate un like ed un commentino. Se non l'avete ancora fatto...cosa aspettate?!
Iscrivetevi al mio fantasmagorico canale e seguitemi su tutti gli altri social